lots and lots of people are trying to
cancel joe rogan they're applying
pressure to spotify where his podcast
lives and of course the spotify
executives they're under fire are they
going to kick them off the platform are
they not they've invested a lot of money
what do they do well now all of a sudden
joe rogan has other options rumble a
brand new fast-growing video platform
yesterday came out and offered him 100
million dollars over a four-year period
to leave spotify and join rumble now
rumble has been growing incredibly
quickly they launched in 2013 they've
got almost 40 million active monthly
users and they continue to hang their
hat on the idea that they will not
censor the people on their platform they
say that they believe in free speech
they say that they believe in
anti-censorship and so ultimately their
pitch to rogan is come get paid and come
be free now of course joe rogan is one
of the most popular podcast in the world
he's the number one show on spotify in
93 different markets he's the most
listened to podcast every single month
in more than 30 markets including the
united states and his listenership since
he moved to spotify has grown by 75
simply joe rogan has a popular podcast
joe rogan has the trust of tens of
millions of people around the world but
the most dangerous thing about joe rogan
is that joe rogan is the mainstream
media joe rogan's episode brings more
audience than all of the mainstream
media including people like tucker
carlson hannity fox news the ingram
angle rachel maddow msnbc cnn etc joe
rogan's audience is massive compared to
these legacy television and radio shows
joe rogan is the mainstream media for
tens of millions of people around the
world and joe rogan's format of having
long-form conversations where he brings
in experts and allows them simply to
talk it isn't five minute clips it isn't
simply trying to get headline grabbing
comments instead he has real
conversations with real people about
nuance and trying to understand what is
going on now joe rogan is very unlikely
to go ahead and take this rumble offer
he's getting paid a lot of money by
spotify and he's already made a career
decision to go ahead and bet the future
of his podcast on that platform but
there's plenty of other people who are
sitting in the cheap seats saying maybe
you should think about it including
people like ted cruz saying big tech
sucks spotify gives in to the mob
they're cowards joe rogan should move to
rumble video now ultimately joe rogan is
getting a crash course in sovereignty
he's understanding that sometimes it's
best to have no bosses to have no
platform that can kick you out joe rogan
is a man who understands what he wants
and he continues to defy all of the
external pressure he's definitely said
some dumb things in the past he himself
has said that they were stupid and he's
apologized for it but where he goes from
here nobody knows i ultimately think
that he's going to continue to get more
and more orange build on bitcoin and
ideas around self-sovereignty and
eventually whether it's before or after
the spotify deal actually ends joe rogan
will move to his own platform whether
it's one he creates or one that his
friends help him create joe rogan
deserves to have a free voice and people
have a desire to listen to these
long-form conversations and joe rogan's
going to do everything he possibly can
to get into a position where no one can
pressure him the mob can't pressure him
a platform can't pressure him and
regardless of what you think he's going
to continue to have these conversations
he's going to continue to allow people
to think for themselves and whether
people like it or not that's a good
thing for society joe rogan is going to
become a bitcoiner joe rogan's gonna get
orange build further and further on
self-sovereignty and joe rogan
eventually is gonna have this podcast
hosted on the open internet where anyone
can listen and no one can censor him